Stephen Glickman you're here at the
Saturn Awards of the co-host of the
Saturn podcast with this lady over here
tell me as a nerve when you grow up as a
kid as a nerd as a geek did you ever
think you'd end up here yes every hour
of the day no yes I didn't well yes this
as soon as I knew that the Saturn Awards
existed I wanted to be a part of it I
didn't know how I didn't know anyone
involved and I slowly just wiggled my
way around until I found some wonderful
people who are on the board and the
people involved and I just kept saying I
want to do something I want to be
involved I don't know how to be involved
but let me do something and and then
they said well I host two podcasts one
for Western Sound which is a very
serious and heavy long-winded interview
show hour hour and a half two hour-long
show and the other one is the nighttime
show which I've been doing for four
years with my friends so they were like
well why don't you come to the Saturn
Awards podcast do live from Saturn and
bringing it bringing a co-host and I was
like Tiffany Smith is the only person
I'd want to co-host with and I got so
lucky she was available and she knows
way more than I do and I know my fair
share when it comes to toys there's very
few other people I'm friends with that
are that know more than me what happens
that guy stuff but but just pure
comic-book knowledge Tiffany Smith kicks
my ass constantly we had a whole
argument her and I about rogue one where
ice she said that she loved rogue one
and I said not a big fan of rogue one
because everyone in the movie is dead
spoiler alert yeah well you know I don't
I like having action figures all my toys
I want a bunch of dead people I don't
play with dead people what am I crazy Oh
[Music]
everyone's dead that's not fun and she
was like you're judging it based off of
the action figures like that's it and
that's not a fair way to judge it and we
like how the whole thing it was really
fun it's great it's the kind of humor
you get it's fun to like have that be
your job you know where you're arguing
about rogue one
you know trust me edit yeah that's what
it's all about it's what you guys are
all about Steve what can we look forward
next from you man what do you got going
on my first big stand-up album through
800-pound gorilla
Records comes out near the end of the
year it's called voices in my head and
we recorded it at the Ice House in
Pasadena two shows and mixed them
together stormy Daniels came out to come
watch me hello do my album and I do a
lot of impressions of certain
presidential people so she she was there
to come root me on Rudy cheer me on to
roll up a magazine but she has I'm just
asking oh god it got rough no surprise
we went to Denny's afterwards oh no an
uber driver drove stormy Daniels and I
and a few other folks over to Denny's at
2:00 in the morning it was weird man
it was weird that's an L a story that's
what that is all about that's a frickin
comedy album that's what that is you're
gonna have to check it out all right
it's difficult I think so much man great
to see you again man take care